on parlait souterrain le métro de moscou
que nous dans le monde entier pour sa
beauté sans parler de sa viabilité et sa
vitesse par dans la seconde guerre
mondiale 7 merveilles artistiques à
sauver des vies
le vent de juillet 1941 en mois après le
début de la guerre moscou faisait face à
sa première attaque aérienne pendant les
bombardements jusqu'à un demi millions
de moscovites ont trouvé refuge dans le
métro aleph tino baranova âgé de 9 ans à
l'époque était avec sa soeur et sa mère
parmi ceux qui descendait sous terre
presque chaque soir quand il y avait une
alerte aérienne on nous faisait
descendre dans le métro
et donc nous descendions dans le métro
il y avait une rame à quai seules les
femmes enceintes et celles avec des
bébés y étaient admises ou les personnes
âgées très faible il donnait midi kiné
tous les autres on les faisait descendre
par un escalier en bois devant la
première voiture dans le tunnel pendant
tout le bombardement on restait dans le
tunnel il n'y avait nulle part où
s'asseoir
lors d'une nuit de bombardement
particulièrement intensifs il y avait
trop de monde dans les tunnels et alex
steen a failli suffoquait moi je jouais
un vieil homme a dit mr soulevé vos
enfants au dessus de vos têtes et
faites-les passait sur le quai pour
qu'il ne crève pas ici c'est ce qu'il a
dit parce qu'il n'y avait pas d'air vous
pouvez imaginer ça nous étions petits et
nous les petits on nous a sauvés et fait
passer pour nous remettre sur le quai
jetons monoplace pour moi bbc et de
réseau et une fois le raid aérien
terminé les parents se sont levés et ont
récupéré leurs enfants c'est arrivé une
seule fois nous sommes restés debout
pendant tout le bombardement en
attendant l'annoncé fin de l' alerte fin
de l' alerte le raid aérien est terminée
pendant la guerre le métro servait de
transport et de refuge
mais on y trouvait aussi en hôpital une
bibliothèque et même un cinéma
pourquoi avons nous eu un nombre
relativement bas de victimes et de morts
parce que dans les premiers mois de la
guerre beaucoup de travail a été
accomplie pour préparer des abris pour
la population le métro de moscou est
célèbre pour son ordre et sa propreté
les stations ont été nettoyés et
désinfectés tous les jours on se prépare
est vraiment pour faire tout ça
le métro cessé de fonctionner en tant qu
à bria 5 heures du matin mais certains
passagers restés pour aider le personnel
de la station et faire le ménage pendant
la guerre tout le pays a vécu un même
élan le front et l'arrière formé en tout
tout le monde littéralement tout le
monde essayait de faire tout son
possible et encore plus pour la victoire
au front bien sûr c'était dur mais à
l'arrière les gens travailler et ne
quittait pas leur poste pendant 10 12
heures voire plus non pas parce que
quelqu'un les forcer à le faire mais
parce qu'il voulait vraiment faire plus
bursa
[Applaudissements]
pourvu qu'il n'y ait plus de guerre
répète souvent les anciens combattants
pourvu que ces murs voix seulement les
passagers et pas de réfugiés